when you look at the geography now of
the movies that are being made do you
like what's happening do you think it's
too much are there too many streaming
platforms I mean I I think there's so
many different
rabbit holes for people to fall down you
know when I was the thing about the brat
pack to go back there was only it was a
very unified youth culture there was one
thing and so everyone knew the brat pack
that's why every one of that is doing
now there are a million little things so
there isn't that kind of unified thing
but I think it's fantastic you know the
first thing I ever heard in this when I
came into Show Business was oh it's so
hard now it's so hard you should have
been here a few years ago when we got
tours oh now it's so and all I've ever
heard is how hard it is anybody that
says that's magical okay thanks Sharon
I'm not at all interested in here
anything you have to say you know what I
mean don't tell me how hard it is it's
just like I know no but it's always been
harder to always be hard yeah go go do
your thing and like shut up
you know what I mean yeah that's that's
the perfect way to end do your thing and
shut up